you're saying he did not say make some
comment about you'll kill yourself and
when you're gone your parents will be
secretly glad that you're gone because
they'll be relieved of the burden that
you caused them and the shame he never
said that I I'm not telling you I
remember it is
yeah we've talked about that before like
what if because because that that script
is like a fortune it's a four chance
right I've heard it the the job and so
like it would be interesting because I
haven't been on the show where I've been
like the Deep fakes are terrifying if
you have watched a deep fake I know it's
not Walsh you're really sure you didn't
say that everybody
but I watched it that's why he said he
said you are eerie and you are
off-putting and people will look at you
and see you as something pitiable all
right and I'll watch it again that is
the extent that we're calling mean also
I really hope you can find this video
I'm sorry yeah I I had so many opinions
on this topic and now you I've lost all
my confidence because I feel like I fell
for a Nigerian scam